it's hard to cover everything you need
to do to launch an app in one lesson but
there are a few main points we want you
to take away from this lesson your
launch is one exciting day but actually
you launch new things all the time
you'll be iterating experimenting and
learning new things you want to be ready
with all the things for your launch but
you'll be experimenting with the new
things once you do launch don't try to
outsmart the search engine or the
reporters you're trying to get to do
press coverage for your app do it make
sense and do what's relevant for your
users you're much more likely to find
success that way and don't ignore user
feedback or reviews it's not only going
to help you improve your product but
it'll also help you optimize your App
Store performance we look forward to
seeing you next lesson when we talk
about online marketing